it feels like
something is breaking loose in the
conversation and the visibility of the
conversation around loudly hypothesis
does it not
um in service of that i would say uh hey
zach you can show our screen here for
the moment this is in the telegraph
today
uh which is a british paper did the
coven 19 virus really escape from abu
han lab
fingers have been pointed at bats
pangolins in a shuttered wet market but
what if the truth is altogether more
alarming this um published today by matt
ridley analina chan
elena chan being one of the scientists
who has been tirelessly working
on trying to figure this out and
um and there was also a piece an
editorial i think in wapo and washington
post this week
yep and uh yeah
there have been three i think there
wasn't another one but i've forgotten
which publication it was in
um but anyway yes something is clearly
breaking
loose and i think this has multiple
levels of relevance because on the one
hand there's the question
and i was very pleased to see
matt and alina address this in terms of
the answer to where this virus came from
is i think they say it's maybe the most
important question of the century and
i agree with them i don't think we fully
understand
what we will be able to derive from the
answer to that but i know
full well there will be important
aspects once we know
whatever the answer is if it's a natural
origin we need to know that because for
one thing
if it's a natural origin it's a very
bizarre natural origin it doesn't fit
any of the others that we know about
and so we will learn something about
what is possible
that is very important on the other hand
well it
the the originally proposed
hypothesis which is presented as fact
and you can't question it right for sars
kobe 2
was originated in a bat ended up in the
wet market through smuggled pangolins
yes which is you know clear there's just
there's just
no evidence for this at this point
practically or there's a lot of evidence
against
yes but the origin story that um
is the mainstream origin story for
sarsko v1
is parallel to that and so like you know
it seems
it seems like a reasonable thing to have
thought at first assuming that all of
this is organic and these are good faith
players that sars kobe 1
was originally in a horseshoe bat and
then showed up in a market in
um in a secondary you know having having
spilled over into a secondary host in um
what some kind of kind of run
uh palm civet palm civet yeah palm civet
so this was a wet market situation right
um but it still doesn't match okay
so i must say there are questions about
the original
what stars so and the proposal on
service cov2
do not match the evidence there's
something new going on here because in
sars kovi one
you did have rapid evolution of this
pathogen
in humans that's one thing that you
would absolutely
i don't want to say it's required
because i could imagine
you know in the way that birds and
people or pigs and people
exchange certain viruses back and forth
it's possible that you're part of a
long-standing system
and therefore the evolution has already
taken place at the point something
uh crosses over but in this case that's
not what appears to be going on
and so the idea of a virus that is well
adapted to humans to
to begin with and therefore takes off
like a shot is unique and unlike sarsko
v1
right so just just to be clear about
what you're saying i think there are a
lot of
sort of dangling modifiers in there um
this is the second trick to which you
have referred both on bill maher and
many times
on on on here and maybe even in joe
rogan when you're on
on rogan last june um the you know
the the one trick is of zoonotic
diseases is switching hosts
and there you know there are a lot of
additional tricks but the other
major trick that we saw with sarri's
cov2 is
well that we see with anything that
becomes pandemic is then being able to
rapidly spread between humans between
individuals between crown specifics of
the species of the new
host into which it is spilled over and
um
that will almost always take
time to evolve that capability
in the pathogen will take time to evolve
and what was so notable
about sarsko v2 is that it was it had
both tricks on board as soon as we
started
hearing about it or there's something
that we've missed or there's something
that we've missed sure
um okay so
a there's the speed b there's the
evidence it would leave
in the phylogeny right so if you do the
phylogeny you would have diversity that
we don't see here in the initial
thing so it's possible there's some
phase of the story we just don't know
if this is a natural origin story you
know the thing that gets said
is it could have circulated somewhere
else
that we still haven't detected and then
you know somebody takes a train and they
end up in wuhan and we notice it and
it's already adapted because it's been
uh circulating and evolving um but the
point is okay
there's been an awful lot of pressure to
find evidence of that there is no
evidence of that yet
and so what we are left with is an is an
anomaly one way or the other and the
answer to that anomaly
is vitally important to figuring out
what to do
um and people have not uh alina and
matt were very good about pointing out
that it's there though they don't say
what the value
is um but um there's that and then
there's the other question which is more
obvious which is if this is a lab leak
even if it didn't do anything for us
with respect to
uh preparing and fighting uh kovit going
forward
it would do something for the next
pandemic which we are likely to cause by
the same route
if if lab leak it is likely to have been
at least partially a result of the gain
of function
and research that involves serial
passaging and if
that research continues um lab leaks are
likely to continue to happen down the
road
right and in fact one of the things that
shows up in a lot of the
good reporting on this is that there is
a long
catalog of accidents where things have
leaked out of labs this is unprecedented
in one regard and in another way it's
completely mundane
um you know that nothing about covet is
mundane but the fact
of something having leaked out of a lab
would be anything but new yeah and i
guess i mean just one more
important distinction between sarsko v1
and ii is precisely that sorry's kobe 1
did not become a global pandemic it
precisely
lacked being very good at that second
trick it was able to move between humans
but not super fast and not nearly as
effectively as stars kobe 2 seemed to
come out of the starting gates being
able to do so it burned out which is
another
typical thing so you know typical thing
for a
natural zoonotic spillover yet exactly
um so but to the second point i don't
want to take too much time here but
there's two issues happening in parallel
one
is what the hell is covid and
why does it behave the way it does and
where did it come from super important
covid or cyrus kobe too the disease or
the pathogen
i was calling it covet just because the
you know the pandemic the
the impact on people is the important
thing but obviously the causal agent is
you know is where the evidence lives
but totally separately from that
this story as you point out something
new is breaking loose
this is a very rare example
of the the gated institutional
narrative not having effectively
silenced some
uncomfortable awful possibility that
needs to be investigated and so
that exceptional fact what it is that
allowed
this discussion to actually move in the
direction of something reasonable and
although those of us who believe lab
leak is a possibility differ
i believe widely on how likely we think
it is
um it's also worth noting though that in
ridley and chan's
uh piece in the telegraph today they
finish
by listing a whole number of
virologists and epidemiologists
who in the early days were saying
very very absolute things about uh
this it not being a possibility and um
in fact i believe i
did not actually go back and check to
make sure this is true but that like 27
authored paper
that was published in i think nature
earlier than pedemics saying there's no
way this is a natural zoonotic spillover
there's no way this is a lab leak
um are now when asked
by jan or ridley and and um they say and
are willing to go on the record saying
well yes it's a possibility yeah and so
we are seeing
we are also seeing a move on the part of
the scientists some of whom were
involved in participating
in silencing this and silencing actual
scientific inquiry in the first place
so you know great that we are actually
people are actually now saying
yes it's a possibility but i would
really not i would really
not want to lose the history here that
that
those people who have been involved and
you know it persists you know we're
still
being called conspiracy theorists and
anti-scientific for
questioning what the authorities have
already declared is true and stamped it
on everyone's foreheads
um like that that is still alive and
well and it's still dominant
but sort of slowly behind the scenes
you're beginning to see movement
by the actual scientists who never
should have come out as certain as they
did in the first place that was
big part of the problem yeah it wasn't
certain then and there was a
rush to circle the wagons around that
certainty which caused i think a lot of
people who were paying slightly less
attention to believe it actually was
certain
which made it very difficult to i mean
yeah as as i said on mar as i said here
you know because
because the possibility of a lab leak
came out of trump's mouth
you know half the country immediately
said no way no how and you know
and the media facilitated that
mainstream media said oh if he said it
you know orange man says it it must not
be true guess what guys that's not only
not the way science works it's not the
way reality works
it doesn't matter who says it if it's
true it's true yeah and you know this
story is one
as with all of these stories the nuanced
position
that follows the evidence and
extrapolates responsibly from it
lands on a slate of conclusions that
doesn't belong in some
camp right you know is there a
possibility of a lab leak here
yes the evidence so far points in that
direction and not the other direction
but not conclusively on the other hand
does that mean that this is a chinese
virus no there's an awful lot of
evidence
pointing to the fact of an international
failure
of the proper safety it's an
international
collaboration virus yes an international
collaboration virus yeah and so the
point is you know this isn't going to
play for one team or the other and
you've you know you've been fed
two possibilities and but they're both
wrong
certainly and the the right thing is
going to involve
having to parse these details but okay
actually i actually want to muddle this
a little bit more
politically for people because i think i
think that actually will help
people lose their but i'm on the blue
team therefore i believe this i'm on the
red team therefore i believe this
stuff which is that gain of function
research
has been contentious in the scientific
community since it began
and it became it it rose to the top of
people's concerns sufficiently that in i
think it was 2000
i can't remember 2014 or 2015 that is
during the obama administration
um there was a moratorium at the federal
level in the united states
put on gain of function research in the
u.s
stopped then now that actually probably
facilitated some of this collaboration
that then moved it off
offshore which we're not going to go
there right now but
that moratorium that the obama
administration put on exactly this gain
of function research was in fact lifted
by the trump administration at the end
of his
first year and in 20 at the end of 2017
and so which team are you playing for
now like
how how does that stuff make you feel
about
who the good guys are and who the bad
guys are guess what again reality
doesn't care what you think
or the politics of the people involved
or whether or not they're right or wrong
about other stuff
you know this virus has an origin and we
don't know what it is yet
but you know a year ago we were already
you know as you say the wagons were
already being circled on
there was only one story that we are
going to talk about says the scientific
community
we are scientists we are in the
scientific community and
we never wanted to be part of a
situation
which says ah you don't need to know the
evidence but we've already decided what
the truth is
nope not science and if going forward
you want this never to happen again you
need to
empower people to actually um
deal with the a la carte conclusions
rather than signing up for a slate in a
team
right the whole the whole point is that
this is not a clear story this is a
screw up at multiple levels
we know that it's a screw up at multiple
levels even if it is natural origin
right the fact is we suddenly are all
aware that these viruses are being
enhanced in laboratories
this is an obvious hazard whether or not
it actually spilled over from the lab
this time
but you absolutely have to have a
free scientific discussion that then
is allowed to impact policy without
polarizing this because
the polarization is going to have played
a huge role
if this is a lab leak it's going to have
played a huge role in
this the mother of all self-inflicted
[Music]
wounds
you